back here at home the nevada task force
one urban search and rescue team has
been activated and deployed by fema
madison kimbrough heard from the fire
chief of the clark county fire
department as they were gearing up to
head out today she joins us live with
the details on that madison
set to be one of the most powerful
hurricanes to ever strike the u.s
louisiana is going to need all the help
they can get and southern nevada is
ready to assist clark county officials
say the team which is one of 28 in the
nation consists of 35 firefighters from
across the valley along with other
personnel specifically clark county
henderson las vegas and north las vegas
fire departments team leaders were sent
out to depart early this afternoon this
of course isn't the first time the
nevada task force one has been sent out
on a mission having assisted in some of
the biggest natural disasters in history
for example in texas hurricane harvey
that was back in 2017 and of course
hurricane katrina in o5 earlier today
crews were packing up gear and luggage
ready to assist crews in baton rouge
they're prepared to do
any any number of rescues
whether it's
swift water
still water
structural issues
anything that they might find down there
chief steinbeck also mentioned that they
were put on alert on friday that they
may be going down to help and then this
morning is when they were told to leave
currently there's no telling how long
southern nevada officials will be down
there it could be up to 14 days or
longer depending on conditions let's
send it to sally to see how conditions
are currently looking